*Discussion hors caméra*
Salut, aujourd'hui je suis dans les loges du Grand Point Virgule
Pour la nouvelle édition des Hallucinations collectives et autres illusions fantastiques
Et je suis de nouveau avec Renald Zapata
Vous vous souvenez, on avait fait une vidéo ensemble qui doit s'afficher par là, autour de moi au moment où je vous parle
On avait fait un truc à base de dessins parce que c'est un speed-painter
Il a cette capacité à peindre très rapidement quelqu'un, sur une grande toile et sur scène, et c'est juste impressionnant
Ce que je me demande
C'est comment ça se passe le cheminement pour faire ça
RZ - Il y a une phase de recherches iconographiques, si tu veux...
*Rires* FO - Les embrouilles...
Le mec il fait les Schtroumpfs (imitation) "On va faire une recherche iconographique"
RZ - A partir de là, il y a les premiers croquis
ça démarre avec une petite maquette
Je vais me le transposer en grand, sur mon mur
Et là, je vais commencer à réfléchir : "Bon bah, par quoi je vais commencer, comment on se repère là-dedans"
Parce que j'ai une grande toile noire, etc.
Alors d'abord, la première chose, c'est que le motif, le visuel, on doit bien l'avoir en tête
Faut savoir qu'une tête, c'est quelque chose qui est complètement quadrillé, en fait
Je vais analyser ton visage de manière complètement mathématique
FO - Fais moi une analyse mathématique
RZ - Alors, de ton menton jusqu'au sommet du crâne, si je coupe au milieu, je vais tomber sur tes yeux
Déjà, ça, c'est un repère majeur
Ensuite de tes yeux à ton menton, si je coupe encore en deux (en plus on a du bol, tu tombes assez bien dans le cadre)
On va tomber sur la base du nez
Et ensuite je vais couper encore à nouveau en deux.
Et là je vais tomber sur la ligne de bouche
Donc tu vois, tu rentres tout à fait dans le canon de Polyclète, il n'y a pas de problème
FO - Dans le ?
RZ - Dans le canon de Polyclète
FO - Tu m'insultes pas
RZ - Voilà
FO - Toi tu découpes tout ça et après, ça te permet de te repérer quand tu fais ton truc
Voilà, et après, bah, il y a des..., après on adapte les techniques de peinture à vue, du dessin à vue
Quand on prend une mesure, avec notre crayon, t'as déjà vu hein ?
Donc là, c'est la même chose, mais qui va beaucoup plus vite
Après on a des cas où on va faire des profils, ça, ça change rien à la grille
FO - Ah bah oui, je t'ai même vu dessiner à l'envers
RZ - Alors dessiner à l'envers. L'idée, c'est qu'encore une fois, on connaît bien son sujet, mais on le connaît bien à l'envers
Je dis toujours : "Tu connais par coeur ton alphabet, tu le récites sans problème, dis-le moi à l'envers"
FO - Moi je vais le faire, ça va te saoûler, mais...*Rires* RZ - Oui, voilà
Une fois que tout ça est bien imbriqué dans la tête
Après on va, avouons-le, il y a quand même un gros travail de préparation, de "chorégraphie" entre guillemets
FO - En plus de ça, ce qu'il ne dit pas parce qu'il est modeste, mais, parfois, il autorise les gens à choisir parmi un choix plus ou moins restreint
ça veut dire qu'à force de travail, tu as tout un catalogue comme ça dans ta tête. RZ - Oui, voilà
FO - ça permet de te repérer et dans ce cas-là, il faut que tu retrouves ta mécanique, avec ta musique
RZ - Exactement, bon alors là, à froid, j'ai une petite part d'impro quand même, parce que
imaginons que je tombe sur un personnage que je n'ai pas fait depuis pas mal de temps
J'ai son image en tête, parce que j'ai révisé un peu mes fiches pendant la semaine
Mais par contre, l'ordre exact, il y a peut-être un manque
On va dire que là-dessus, il y a entre 10 et... FO - Tu fais Mickaël Jackson avec le nez de Depardieu
Si nous par exemple, nous on te regarde, mais moi je te regarde parce que je suis là
si je veux essayer de reproduire déjà un personnage, un visage
Il faut que je me réfère à ce quadrillage d'abord, et que je travaille partie par partie
RZ - Et tu vas t'apercevoir que dans ce quadrillage, il y a des choses qui rentrent pas
Et c'est ce qui fait qu'on ressemble à ce qu'on est
FO - Ah oui, c'est ce qui n'est pas réellement symétrique...
RZ - Exactement, voilà, quelqu'un va avoir un nez un peu plus court, un peu plus long, ça c'est classique
Et tu as la forme générale du visage, tu vas avoir un oeuf, tu peux avoir plutôt un carré
FO - Moi, je commence à voir Sleepy Hollow, le cavalier sans tête
Je vais faire son col, je vais faire un petit col
Ah mais faut que je fasse un cheval
C'est hyper intéressant que tu nous expliques comment tu faisais en fait
Moi ce qui m'intéresse, c'est le point de vue mental en fait
Je me demandais à quel point tu allais jusqu'à la projection
Du coup c'est hyper intéressant parce que c'est ce qu'on voit les mercredis et les samedis sur cette chaîne
C'est que tu passes par les maths et par la visualisation
Donc voilà, il n'y a pas de secret, il faut aller sur la chaîne de Reynald et vous allez voir en action tous ce qu'il vient de vous expliquer
C'est la première fois qu'on fait une vidéo comme ça en fait, où c'est ni un tour, ni une astuce, ni un vlog
J'avais juste envie qu'il nous explique comment il faisait
Si ce genre de format-là vous a plu, vous pouvez me le faire comprendre, avidement, d'un petit pouce en l'air
Si je le quadrille, regarde, il y a le pouce qui dépasse
Vous pouvez aussi laisser des commentaires, je vous y répondrai.
Si vous avez des questions à poser sur Reynald, peut-être que lui passera y répondre, je ne sais pas
Je peux le mentaliser pour ça
Rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao !